Salut !
Aujourd'hui, on va parler
d'un sujet plutôt douloureux.
Est-ce que vous vous êtes
déjà demandé
comment font ces gens pour marcher
dans des braises ardentes ?
Sans hurler de douleur.
Alors que moi, si je prends
un vieux Lego qui traîne,
dans mon orteil,
je me roule de douleur.
En clair, est-ce qu'on est
tous égaux face à la douleur ?
C'est une question
que je me suis posée.
Et surtout, est-ce qu'on peut arriver
à mieux supporter la douleur ?
Vous allez voir,
c'est assez passionnant.
Loïc, générique.
- Aie !
- Commençons par la base.
Qu'est ce qu'il se passe dans
notre cerveau, quand on a mal ?
Imaginez, vous tombez
dans les escaliers.
Là, il y a vos récepteurs
nerveux de la douleur
qui vont activer des régions
de votre cerveau,
comme le Thalamus, le tronc cérébral
ou d'autres régions du cortex.
Le message nerveux sera donc interprété
comme étant une sensation désagréable.
Parce qu'au final la douleur,
c'est juste ça.
C'est si je me pince,
en fait c'est un message
qui est envoyé à mon cerveau.
Et ce message étant interprété comme,
"ça fait mal", pour qu'on réagisse.
Parce qu'il y a danger
à cet endroit là.
Ni plus ni moins.
En réalité, nous ne sommes pas
du tout égaux face à la douleur,
on est tous différents
dans notre capacité à détecter,
donc cette information,
et à la tolérer.
Est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé
d'avoir mal quelque part,
genre vous vous cognez et là
il y a une personne qui vous dit :
"Non mais c'est rien,
t'en fais des caisses, t'es douillet".
Non mais entre nous.
C'est pas un genre le truc qui énerve
quand tu te fais mal et qu'on te dit :
"Eh t'es douillet".
Alors que toi,
tu as trop mal en vrai.
- Ouais, en vrai, tu sais les gens
ne peuvent pas connaître ta douleur.
- ça c'est vrai.
- Mais c'est pas leur douleur à eux.
- C'est une excellente réflexion,
on va y revenir dans la vidéo.
- Merci.
- De rien.
Déjà, il y a une part de génétique
dans tout ça.
Selon une équipe de chercheurs
de l'université d'Edimbourg,
il y aurait des gènes qui nous rendent
plus ou moins vulnérables à la douleur.
Des gènes qui sont souvent responsables,
d'ailleurs, des douleurs chroniques.
En gros, merci papa maman.
En plus de ça, notre sensibilité
à la douleur est modelée
en fonction des expériences
douloureuses qu'on a déjà vécues.
Donc les moments où on s'est cogné,
où on s'est fait mal.
Et en vrai, on a tous entendu une fois
dans notre vie ce cliché, selon quoi,
les hommes seraient d'ailleurs
plus douillets que les femmes.
Et d'après une étude scientifique,
eh bien c'est faux, mais un peu vrai.
C'est pas si simple.
- Ah bah super l'étude.
- Non mais c'est...
- C'est vrai, mais c'est faux.
- C'est frau, c'est frau !
C'est frais.
Voilà donc la réponse
à ce vieux débat,
voilà c'est dit,
on va assumer maintenant.
On ressent la douleur
plus intensément,
mais je vais vous dire pourquoi.
L'expérience a été menée
sur 41 hommes
et 38 femmes
âgés de 18 à 40 ans.
Ainsi que sur des rongeurs.
Peu importe l'âge de rongeurs.
Première étape, les scientifiques ont
d'abord appliqué une source de chaleur
plusieurs fois au même endroit
sur le corps des volontaires,
et donc aussi des rongeurs.
De façon répétée, les sources de chaleur
ont provoqué une petite douleur,
rien de méchant,
rien de bien grave.
Sur une échelle de 0 à 100,
les volontaires ont dû noter leur douleur.
Zéro étant l'absence de douleur,
100 étant la plus vive douleur
qu'ils aient jamais ressenti dans leur vie.
Du côté des rongeurs,
on leur a demandé de noter,
il l'ont pas fait.
Donc ça, pas cool les rongeurs.
Du coup l'intensité a été mesurée
en fonction de la rapidité
à laquelle le rongeur s'éloignait
de la source de chaleur.
On se disait, plus il part vite
et plus c'est désagréable.
Deuxième étape !
Quelques heures plus tard,
chacun des participants était
muni d'un brassard de tensiomètre,
gonflé à fond.
Vous savez, les trucs là qu'on met
pour prendre la tension.
Et ça fait :
Et là tu dis :
"Eh il va m'écraser le bras".
Et pas du tout.
On a demandé aux participants de faire
des exercices avec ce brassard
pendant environ 20 minutes.
Ce qui là, pour le coup,
provoque une plus grosse douleur.
Une douleur plus intense
qu'avant en tout cas.
Les rongeurs ont quant à eux,
été aspergés par des gouttes
de vinaigre dilué,
dans le but de provoquer
des petits maux d'estomac.
Troisième étape, le lendemain.
Toujours dans le même endroit,
les volontaires et les rongeurs
ont reçu le même protocole
que la deuxième étape.
Donc toujours en notant la douleur
sur une échelle de zéro à 100.
Et le résultat est un peu bizarre.
Selon les cobayes hommes,
l'intensité de la douleur était plus forte
que celle du jour précédent,
alors que le protocole
était resté identique.
Et les rongeurs mâles ont d'ailleurs
davantage réagi que les rongeurs femelles.
Par contre, c'est pas du tout le cas
pour les femmes ou les souris femelles.
Les chercheurs affirment
que les hommes conservent
des souvenirs plus précis de leurs
douleurs antérieures que les femmes.
Et le fait qu'ils gardent la douleur,
plus facilement en mémoire
que les femmes,
créer un phénomène d'anticipation.
Et cette anticipation à la douleur.
Tu te dis :
"Ah là je vais avoir mal".
Donc tu as une anxiété qui nait.
Et cette anxiété là
accentue la douleur.
La mémoire joue donc un rôle
sur l'intensité de la douleur.
Jeffrey Mogil, neuroscientifique
à l'université McGill à Montréal
et auteur principal de l'étude, déclare :
"A notre avis, les souris et les hommes
anticipaient la pose du brassard
ou l'injection du vinaigre.
Et chez les sujets mâles,
le stress d'anticipation a accru
la sensibilité à la douleur".
Les femmes quant à elles,
ne semblent pas appréhender la douleur
et n'étaient pas
particulièrement stressées.
En fait, ce serait ça le secret.
Les souris femelles avaient
un faible taux de cortisol dans le sang.
La cortisol,
c'est l'hormone du stress.
Il faut savoir que
les souris mâles castrées,
donc dépourvues de testostérone,
n'ont pas ressenti
de douleur supérieure.
- Donc les femmes sont plus fortes
que les hommes !
- C'est pas vraiment ça non plus.
Si les hommes ont une plus forte
résistance physique,
ils ont par contre, plus tendance
à imprimer les souvenirs douloureux,
donc dans leur cerveau.
Mais pourquoi les femmes
ne conservent-t-elles pas
autant de souvenirs douloureux ?
C'est ça la question.
Mogil a une théorie selon laquelle,
les femmes on peut-être une
plus grande expérience face à la douleur.
Et c'est peut-être pour cette raison
qu'elles sont moins stressées.
Parce qu'elles sont plus soumises
à plus de formes de douleurs.
Est-ce que ça confirmerait
la croyance selon laquelle,
les femmes oublient
la douleur de l'accouchement,
ce qui fait qu'elles sont pas totalement
réticentes à avoir un deuxième enfant ?
Bah c'est pas impossible
selon Mogil.
Le sexe influerait donc
sur la perception de la douleur.
C'est une question d'hormones.
Mais les chercheurs ne savent pas
l'expliquer davantage, jusqu'à présent.
Et je vous tiendrai au courant,
s'il y a d'autres études
qui sortent sur le sujet.
Cette découverte scientifique,
quand même,
permettrait à la science
de progresser dans l'élaboration
de nouveaux traitements
pour les douleurs chroniques.
Qui sont vraiment les pires,
parce que c'est celles
qui ne s'arrêtent jamais.
Selon les experts,
il y a de plus en plus de preuves
pour affirmer que la douleur chronique
serait amplifiée dans la mesure
où on se souvient d'elle,
et donc on l'anticipe.
L'idée, ce serait donc de traiter directement
le mécanisme mémoriel lié à la douleur.
Il faut savoir que 12 millions
de personnes en France,
souffrent de douleurs chroniques.
Donc vraiment, il y a du boulot,
il y a de l'utilité publique.
Et petit aparté.
Parce que sinon, il y a aussi les gens
qui ne ressentent pas du tout la douleur.
Et on appelle ça le syndrome
d'insensibilité à la douleur
ou analgésie congénitale.
Là j'en vois certains dans
les commentaires qui doivent se dire :
"Ouais, mais ça c'est trop stylé,
moi aussi je veux pas sentir la douleur".
Alors en fait, ça c'est vraiment
plus galère qu'autre chose.
C'est un vrai problème,
même vital.
Imaginez, vous faites
un bon petit gâteau.
Vous le sortez du four comme ça,
mais vous ne mettez pas de moufle.
- Des moufles ?
- Ouais.
Tu mets pas de moufle.
- C'est qu'ils sont au ski
à ce moment là.
Bah on appelle ça comment les...?
Des manilles, des maniques ?
Des maniques, je crois !
Bon bref, vous sortez vos gâteaux
sans protéger vos mains.
Et là vous vous brûlez
sans vous en rendre compte.
Vous vous en rendez compte
à partir du moment
où vous sentez l'odeur
de la chair humaine grillée.
Et c'est trop tard,
parce que vous avez une brûlure
au troisième degré.
Donc l'absence de douleur, en fait,
la douleur n'existe pas pour rien,
encore une fois, c'est une information
pour le cerveau, pour dire :
Attention à cet endroit du corps,
il se passe un truc pas cool,
il faut être très vigilant,
il faut arrêter ça.
Si tu ressens plus la douleur,
tu ne fais plus attention à rien
et tu peux te blesser gravement
voire mortellement.
C'est ce qui arrive souvent
à Joe Cameron,
une écossaise atteinte
de ce syndrome extrêmement rare.
Qui ne ressent pas la douleur,
et en oublie certaines choses
basiques, essentielles.
Parce que c'est ça la douleur,
c'est ce qui nous protège.
C'est un signal d'alarme
pour vous dire que quelque chose
ne tourne pas rond
dans votre corps.
Et ces gens qui
ne ressentent pas la douleur
peuvent se blesser ou souffrir d'une
maladie sans s'en rendre compte.
Ce qui peut avoir
des conséquences graves.
Plus impressionnant encore,
en Italie, c'est toute une famille.
La famille Marsili !
Marsili !
Qui a héritée de ce gène
d'insensibilité à la douleur.
La grand mère, ses deux filles
et ses trois petits-enfants.
L'institut Wolfson, de recherche
biomédicale à Londres
et l'université de Sienne
ont identifié un gène
qui serait responsable de la maladie,
si on peut appeler ça une maladie.
Un espoir pour améliorer, du coup,
les traitements médicaux
des maladies chroniques.
A contrario, il y a aussi des gens
qui ont une hypersensibilité à la douleur.
Et là par contre, ça doit être
un peu plus compliqué à gérer.
En gros, c'est la douleur à son extrême.
Le signal nerveux provoque
plus de douleur que la normale.
En gros, on fait ça.
Et là le corps envoie au cerveau :
"ça fait extrêmement mal !".
Alors que pas tant.
Bref, en tout cas j'ai une
bonne nouvelle pour vous.
Il faut savoir qu'on peut apprendre
à dompter la douleur
pour mieux la supporter,
je vous en parlais
au début de la vidéo.
Vous avez déjà vu certainement
ces gens qui marchent sur des braises,
qui s'enfoncent
des clous dans la peau.
Ces gens, qui malgré tout,
n'ont pas l'air de souffrir plus que ça.
C'est genre :
"Ah moi ça va, et toi ça va ?"
"Moi ça va, tiens dis donc
je marche sur des clous, bonne nuit".
Les moines Shaolin par exemple,
ils sont capables de casser
des briques sur leur tête sans broncher.
Ils font ça pépouze !
Il font :
"Ah non, mais il faut casser
des briques, moi j'ai ma tête".
Est-ce qu'ils ont un don particulier ?
Ou est-ce que vous aussi,
derrière votre écran,
vous êtes capable de casser
des briques avec votre front ?
Et bien certains scientifiques affirment
que la pratique de la méditation
pourrait agir sur la gestion
de la douleur en interne.
Lorsqu'on médite,
le rythme cardiaque ralentit un petit peu.
Les muscles se relâchent, etc.
Et plus surprenant,
les signaux nerveux de la douleur
dans le cerveau diminuent, eux aussi.
Et il y a des neurophysiologistes
canadiens qui ont réalisé
une expérimentation pour comparer
la résistance à la douleur
avec 13 volontaires
adeptes de la méditation.
Et 13 autres volontaires lambdas
qui ne faisaient pas de méditation.
Le test est simple.
Une plaque chauffée à différentes
températures, de 43 à 53 degrés,
est pressée sur le mollet
des participants.
Résultat :
La majorité des personnes
du groupe A,
donc les adeptes de la méditation
toléraient la température maximale.
Le groupe B, donc les gens
qui ne font jamais de méditation,
ont commencé à se plaindre
dès 48 degrés.
Aucun des volontaires de ce groupe
n'a atteint la température maximale.
La méditation associe
une respiration plus lente.
Alors c'est 12 respirations par minute
en moyenne pour le groupe A
et 15 respirations par minute
en moyenne pour le groupe B.
Un des étudiants explique
que le fait de ralentir sa respiration
semble correspondre
à une diminution de la douleur
et peut influer
sur le contrôle de la douleur,
en relaxant l'intégralité du corps.
D'autres chercheurs
en Caroline Du Nord,
ont voulu comprendre précisément
ce qu'il se passe dans notre cerveau,
quand la méditation
et la douleur sont associées.
Le Docteur Fadel Zeidan,
de l'université Wake Forest,
a demandé à 15 étudiants familiarisés
à minima avec la méditation,
de passer sous un IRM pour
analyser l'activité de leur cerveau,
avant et après
une séance de méditation.
Il faut savoir que pendant
qu'ils passaient l'IRM,
une petite plaque chauffée à 50 degrés
était appliquée sur leur jambe.
Je sais pas pourquoi c'est...
- C'est le truc ça.
- C'est le truc.
- Pour vérifier la douleur.
- Viens voir.
- Fais voir, petite plaque là.
- Aller, clac sur le mollet !
Le résultat est frappant,
puisque la méditation a diminuée
la douleur de 40% !
C'est énorme.
Un fonctionnement plus faible
du cortex somatosensoriel primaire,
impliqué dans la localisation
des stimuli douloureux a été observé,
comme ça à l'image.
Et selon Fadel Zeidan,
la méditation serait même
plus efficace que la morphine, selon lui.
Alors il ne s'agit pas
d'une suppression de la douleur,
mais bien d'un apaisement
pour mieux la gérer,
mieux supporter l'information
qui arrive au cerveau.
En gros la méditation permettrait
de neutraliser les zones du cerveau,
qui sont normalement impliquées
dans le traitement de la douleur.
Une autre technique
un peu plus surprenante,
pour supporter la douleur.
Et ça vous pouvez le faire
et vous le faites sûrement.
Ce serait de prononcer
des injures, des jurons.
- Genre, Bachibouzouk !
- Qui dit ça Loïc, aujourd'hui ?
- Le capitaine Haddock,
il avait dit ça.
- Je croyais qu'il avait dit...
Je suis sûr que ça vous arrive déjà
de vous faire mal et spontanément...
Je vais m'arrêter là.
C'est ce qui est arrivé à une femme
en train d'accoucher,
qui lors d'un pic de douleur,
s'est littéralement lâchée d'insultes.
Et son mari, Richard Stephens,
qui était psychologue Britannique
à l'université de Keele.
Est resté un peu comme ça,
tu sais :
"Je connaissais pas ma femme
sous cet angle là".
Il s'est dit, c'est quand même
assez intéressant.
Et c'est ce qui l'a poussé
à étudier la question :
Est-ce que dire des gros mots
soulage réellement la douleur ?
Il a mené une petite expérience
avec d'autres chercheurs
en demandant à 92 personnes,
de plonger leurs mains dans
de l'eau glacée et de tenir comme ça.
Entre nous je crois quand même,
que je préfère le petit coup
de la plaque chauffante que ça, mais bon.
Et en même temps
qu'ils plongeaient leurs mains,
ils devaient répéter une grossièreté
comme le mot...
Ou un mot neutre comme table,
ou un mot inventé comme
"Foutch" ou "twizipe".
Est-ce que vous imaginez
juste un instant, sorti du contexte,
un truc un peu chelou.
Genre t'es là dans le bureau,
tu te cognes et tu fais :
"Oh twizipe !".
On sent que ça marche pas.
Les scientifiques ont mesuré
l'effet de ces quatre mots
sur la perception de la douleur.
Tout en analysant
combien de temps les volontaires
étaient capables de laisser leurs
mains immergées dans l'eau glacée.
Résultat, la grossièreté "fuck"
favorise la tolérance à la douleur de 33%.
Tandis que les autres mots
n'ont produit aucun effet particulier.
Le fait de prononcer des jurons
provoque, en fait,
une excitation émotionnelle.
Et cette théorie suggère
que ça provoquerait, du coup,
une atténuation de la douleur.
Il faut savoir que quand
on parle en mode normal,
c'est la partie gauche
du cerveau qui s'active,
la partie qui est plutôt rationnelle.
Et quand on prononce des gros mots,
c'est la partie droite qui est sollicitée,
donc l'hémisphère
qui est associé aux émotions.
L'amygdale s'active pour faire face
au danger, en libérant de l'endorphine.
Et ça c'est des antidouleurs naturels
qu'on a dans le cerveau,
donc c'est un mécanisme naturel
qui nous permet de fuir
dans des situations dangereuses
ou de se battre plus facilement.
Et bah du coup aussi
de mieux supporter la douleur.
L'effet anti-douleur
fonctionnerait d'ailleurs mieux
sur les personnes qui n'utilisent pas
souvent des gros mots.
Et qui l'utilisent qu'à ce moment là.
Bon vous savez ce qu'il vous reste
à faire quand vous avez mal.
Ou sinon, ça c'est le dernier truc,
plutôt que d'être vulgaire,
vous pouvez aussi sourire
quand vous avez mal.
Oui vous m'avez bien compris, sourire.
Il y a des chercheurs
germano-canadiens
qui ont décrété que le sourire
pouvait aider à surmonter la douleur.
En gros, quand on modifie
nos expressions faciales,
ça va de pair avec l'activité
du système nerveux.
Je vous en ai déjà
parlé en vidéo,
c'est un peu comme si vous étiez
en train de tromper votre cerveau.
Vous souriez de douleur,
et votre cerveau interprète
un message positif
qui est susceptible de modifier
le message nerveux.
Il y a une étude qui est très intéressante
qui a été réalisée sur le sujet.
Là ça ferait
une deuxième vidéo d'en parler,
donc je vous la mets description
si vous voulez regarder.
C'est un petit peu long,
mais c'est très très cool.
Donc il y a plein de méthodes
pour mieux supporter la douleur.
La visualisation aussi,
l'hypnose, etc.
Si ça vous intéresse,
dites-le moi en commentaire
et je pourrais vous donner
des petites astuces
dans mes stories sur Instagram,
comme je le fais parfois.
Et si vous avez pas mon Instagram,
c'est celui-là.
Venez me rejoindre.
Pour terminer,
j'ai envie de tester un truc.
ça vous est déjà forcément arrivé
de vous cogner le coude
et de ressentir une décharge électrique
hyper désagréable.
ça part de là et là tu fais :
"Oh là sa maman...twizipe !".
Et bien notez cette douleur
que vous connaissez
dans les commentaires
de zéro à 10.
Zéro étant l'absence de douleur,
et 10 étant la pire douleur
que vous ayez jamais connue.
Et je serais curieux
de lire vos notes
et on fera un peu un comparatif
entre hommes/femmes.
On pourra voir un petit peu
ce qui s'en dégage.
Si vous ne me connaissez pas,
je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard,
ça n'a toujours pas changé.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner,
et d'activer la cloche pour ne pas
rater les prochaines vidéos,
c'est très important.
Ici, je vous mets une vidéo,
sur 6 expériences stylées
qui ont été faites sur le cerveau.
Et ici, je vous mets
une vidéo où je vous montre
comment débloquer
une compétence dans votre cerveau.
Vous allez adorer.
Prenez très soin de vous,
ne vous faites pas mal,
c'est un bon moyen
de résister à la douleur.
A très bientôt, ciao.